hello everyone and welcome back to your
favorite show that takes high art and
throws it into a sporting arena for our
amusement today getting the thumbs up
will be one of two diabolically deep
directors that have combined for seven
deadly sins three batman movies and one
glorious six-pack you do not talk about
Fight Club we don't are we am I'm not
allowed to talk about the minutes anyway
its Fincher vs. Nolan in one corner you
have the dark authentic style of David
Fincher and the other you have the
thinking persons hitmaker in Christopher
Nolan and while Michael Caine will tell
you there's three routes to making a
magic trick on this show there's four
rounds to determine a winner round one
box office round two tomato meter slash
audience score round three characters
and then we'll do a wild-card around to
settle the score pick a card any card
could be an ace a jack or a joke that's
my that impression wasn't the right
Joker was it well let's get it on some
men just want to watch the world but
round one box office
good news Fincher fans there's other
rounds you can win pace yourselves
because look this Nolan guy he teamed up
with that bat fella not one not two but
two and a half times I wrote it on like
the second half of The Dark Knight Rises
impossible
and those flicks crush at the box-office
now Fincher usually makes r-rated movies
so even if kids wanted to see one they
buy a ticket for something else before
sneaking in
I'm just saying anything is possible
maybe this Davey can beat Goliath in the
world of cinematic dollar churning after
all Fincher is no slouch when it comes
to his turning of celluloid into bullion
relying on the strength of critically
acclaimed films like seven in the social
network David Fincher's career earnings
as a director total 1.3 billion dollars
domestically and 3.3 billion worldwide
for an international average of 329
million dollars quite the accomplishment
though not wholly unexpected for a guy
who cut his teeth in the effects of
for Industrial Light and Magic
blockbusters such as Return of the Jedi
and Indiana Jones and the Temple of Doom
speaking of Directors I think that Lucas
fella he's going places right but you
could combine all the money on earth and
on fury 161 and it still wouldn't be
enough to top him Nolan dude has been
lighting up the scoreboard for almost
two decades to the tune of two point
five two billion dollars and five point
eight seven billion dollars over the
globe making for a perfect average of
six hundred and fifty three million
dollars when it's all said and done
that's in no small part thanks to Robins
big brother Bruce the Batman movies have
combined for 3.1 billion dollars across
the world averaging just over a bill
each time Christian Bale puts on that
suit and does that funny thing with his
voice no one's all-time highest grossing
film that's not centered in Gotham City
is inception with 1 billion dollars
internationally and Fincher can also
afford a house in that neighborhood as
his best effort is 7 was seven hundred
and three million dollars worldwide
so yeah it's fair to say Fincher would
have a shot in this category if not for
the Batman but I saw those movies so did
you they're based off a comic book and
they're great at least the first two
okay Oh lay off Fincher's back is not
broken yet but Christopher Nolan does
win the round and takes a one-nothing
lead
- shrieks imagination
round two tomato meter slash audience
score here's where Fincher has a shot
he's been making critical darling films
ever since directly after alien 3 and
the fact that audiences show up to see
them is icing on the spaghetti alien 3
gathered around 44 percent in 1992 but
David quickly rebounded in 95 as seven
nabbed at 81% fresh and his films and TV
had been fresh ever since yes TV counts
mine hunter love death and robots that
all counts if we're sticking with movies
Fincher reached his tomato meter peak
with the social network getting a harder
to prove 96% fresh
I mean dollars isn't cool you know it's
cool you his overall average is very
healthy 78% but I look it's a bad signal
yeah no one's Batman trilogy is eighty
eight point three percent fresh and his
overall resume the average is a
mind-boggling 86 percent you ought to
know you bought it that includes early
films like 2000's memento and his most
recent release come on tenant get here
Dunkirk
both of which are at 93% every movie
known as directed is fresh
I believe it's actually certified fresh
since following and he also gets credit
on Man of Steel which it that's rotten
ah at 56% so close I guess the s on
Superman's chest stands for yeah if you
combine these guys as resumes and form a
top-ten tomato meter list it reads like
a who's who of the most celebrated films
post mm there's inception at 87% and
right next door is gone girl insomnia at
92% and speaking of creeps zodiac is in
there with an 89% Nolan is up for the
moment with the critics but how does the
audience feel about these fellas
they're fans with Nolan his average
audience score is a stellar 88%
meanwhile Fincher also stays fresh with
an 80% I got to think this is where the
directorial style and choices really
factored in Fincher loves to deal with
very dreary sub
matter if Edgar Allan Poe or Emily
Dickinson were around today and they
might be Fisher would be their favorite
director no one can go dark - but when
darkness is ensconced with the most
famous hockey pad critic ever audiences
might tend to resonate a little bit more
ventures best audience score is 96% for
Fight Club
while Noah's trio of memento Batman
Begins and The Dark Knight
each got him his best effort at 94%
Fincher has woken up and gave a sterling
effort in round two but so far it's
Nolan's game he wins the round
and now David Fincher fans are starting
to panic room it's a man let's move on I
thought my jokes were bad now three
characters breaking news into the show
if you're making a movie you are
required to have compelling characters
or at least you should be you need to
know what makes a great character ask
David Fincher or Christopher Nolan
they've been making movies with epic
parts from memorable performers for
almost a combined 5 decades now let's
see who did it the best Christopher
Nolan certainly had help when it came to
his blockbuster comic book flicks joker
Catwoman Batman and Bruce Wayne who is
totally not any of the names I just
mentioned they were already fleshed out
in the picture books for over a half
century before Nolan got his talented
hands on them but I will give him credit
for elevating the stature of all
superhero flicks to follow after the
dark night it was possible to get
nominated and even win an Academy Award
for playing a role in those kind of
movies before Nolan franchises like
Batman had become a joke no pun intended
they were nothing more than an easy
while to sell toys and get us collector
cups at the drive-thru and for the shred
of criticism Nolan has received for a
piece like Dunkirk which audiences
showed up to watch even though it's
artsy look there weren't any memorable
characters I've countered that with the
fact that yeah I can't recall their
names but why did I care about them
while I was watching the movie my
spoiled self couldn't figure out whether
to shove another fist of popcorn down my
gullet or duck for cover and if we're
really searching for great characters
and
one of Christopher Nolan's movies look
no further than Matthew McConaughey's
Cooper in interstellar why are you
whispering they can't hear you
guy Pearce's Leonard in memento or any
of the times Michael Caine has graced us
with his regal presence inception
brought it to another level with a
badass team of dream chasing experts but
it's what Nolan did with Robin Williams
that might be the most impressive in
insomnia he managed to create a world
where arguably the funniest most beloved
human in history became a deranged
murderous psychopath it's thrilling
until the end and it's because you buy
into the characters she's terrified
she's screaming her head off I put my
hand over a mouth and a venom I'm really
scared I'm like the UH scared shitless
that's a lesson David Fincher certainly
learned early on after being thrown into
alien 3 and then rewrites and firings he
could have easily relied on the heroic
Ellen Ripley and a Evil Queen xenomorph
to the point of overkill but he didn't
he instead gave us a prison cell of
remarkable narrow duels led by the
incomparable Charles s Dutton as Dillon
now sure most of that movie is bad
effects and closing garage doors on
aliens but it's the characters and the
performances that venture got from his
thespians that made a lien three a film
that some will say isn't all that bad
dare we say it's a rotten movie we love
I don't have a copy of the book here
wait wait wait really what well let's
get real you can't ever shake the creeps
that one gets from the cast of seven and
zodiac and if it's characters you want
the social network is the superhighway
you should take fleshing out the
enigmatic Mark Zuckerberg Edwin Sean
Parker and the Winkle buy is no easy
task
yet it was them even more so than the
story of Facebook that we all rushed to
social media to rave about after the
credits rolled yes and when we wanted to
go see gone girl who could have guessed
that Rosamund Pike's Amy Dunne would
have given us so many twists turns and
chills unless you cheated and read the
book first yeah you heard me
reading is cheating
one might say that Brad Pitt would be
Fincher's mused as he's appeared in four
films and we know at least two of his
characters by name alone who hasn't made
a Benjamin Button reference at this
point I think most people think Benjamin
Button was like a real guy who aged
backwards not just a weird old baby in a
movie and the other one Tyler Durden yet
not only was Tyler not real he was so
imaginary he entered into all of our
minds and gave us one of the most
enduring characters in cinematic history
I started three fight clubs myself
sensing the movie and I must resign from
all three fight clubs which means a lot
of you been breaking the first rules of
life but hey it's not all bad news
David Fincher you've won the character
round and you cut the lead to one we got
us a ball game folks
we should do this again sometime
wildcard round iconic moments whether
it's floating in a dreamscape hallway or
finally finding out what's in the box
both venture and Nolan have made their
mark on cinema thanks in large part to
the iconic moments they've created and
if you've never seen seven I won't tell
you what was in the box
actually it was kind of a good product
you lie Christopher Nolan can weave
something remarkable regardless of the
budget he has to play with that much was
evident as soon as we see Cobb disappear
in Chris's feature debut following he'd
follow that up with a tremendous tension
build in memento that classic chasing
trope thrown on its ear because we don't
know if Guy Pearce is doing the chasing
or is being chased and if you want
compelling chase sequences throw to
iconic actors into a fog and voila
doesn't matter that they're going slower
than Michael Myers with a bum ankle
there's a fog kids Nolan with a budget
just takes it to another level entirely
and a move that would be replicated by
the MCU placing a giant comic book
franchise in the hands of a director who
cut his teeth in the independent world
of storytelling paid dividends we get
the Dark Knight bank robbery and the
heist in China we also get Nolan himself
favorite sequence with the IMAX friend
the plane jump in the Dark Knight Rises
that dude can wow us with movies that
are one long iconic scene like Dunkirk
and also subvert our expectations simply
by spinning a top and inception also
after those nightmarish elevators in
that movie I refused to get on an
elevator of any sort like a year I will
take the stairs
thank you very much taking the escalator
to the iconic moment hall of fame is
David Fincher alien 3 I'm not gonna lie
to you it's but hey 7 had intense
memorable images of each of the deadly
sins we all saw that and were creeped
out and we didn't trust anything anymore
and we were still shocked by that ending
I didn't open a box for like a year
after that these movies really affect me
Fincher has the unique talent of even
making a conversation in a bar memorable
watching Jake Gyllenhaal and Tony Stark
slowly pieced together the zodiac
killers clues is captivating and when
Sean Parker is selling himself to Mark
Zuckerberg were all buying in to just
Facebook
and while Fincher didn't choose to go
the route of Christopher Nolan with a
resilient superhero series he still
managed to get iconic moments out of
every single movie he crafted the
torture scene in The Girl with the
Dragon Tattoo is disturbing and
unforgettable as is the car accident in
Benjamin Button and in panic room
the break-in scene feels so authentic
you feel like it's your house it's being
robbed I seriously I didn't break into a
house like a year after that and I don't
want any healthy Joe best shielding but
if all else is equal in this round I
can't help but give the tiebreaker to
Fincher simply because he is relentless
with not allowing the audience to get
ahead of him we're always pulling a Def
Leppard
because we're two steps behind or in
Michael Douglas's case 20 steps behind
his character in the game is all of us
watching every Fincher movie
we started out feeling cocky feeling
prepared I've been to the movies before
I got this
how does this work and before the second
act even starts were helpless putty in
his masterful hands bending to his will
until the very end when we can't believe
the soap guy was imaginary the whole
time really but those ABS were real
I'm giving Fincher to W in the wild-card
round and guess what we're all tied up
at two to two Ernest Hemingway once
wrote the world is a fine place and
worth fighting for I agree with the
second part so it's a tie we'll all
shake hands and say good game yeah if
only competition was that simple
I got a declare a winner before I
unleash all you boil viewers unto the
comment section to weigh in yourselves
so anytime I have to make a decision
this tough
I go to my thinking room my own personal
cerebro and while I was sitting on the
toilet I happened upon a great piece by
our own Mark Hoffmeyer he ranked the
Nolan Batman franchise as the second
best action series ever trailing only
Mad Max and that was published right
here at Rotten Tomatoes the link is in
the bio written in 2019 which was 30
years ago so I'll simply add that not
only
those movies epic they say Batman and
the future of superhero movies
forevermore we don't get Iron Man or
Joker or socket boy or ever new comic
book flick is next unless Nolan gives us
his egg on the Caped Crusader you think
Bruce had a tough time climbing out of
that he'll hit with a broken back
try resurrecting Batman after mr. freeze
and company put him on ice oh that's my
exit Joo however my one small gripe with
Nolan is that he doesn't always stick
the landing the Dark Knight Rises
it ended up feeling like it was ripped
out of Batman 1966 and if you liked it
great I wish I did I wish all bone
brakes would heal after five days but
interstellar also me entered to the
finish line again it certainly has its
fans but one could argue that the best
Nolan ending ever is the open-ended one
at the Dane Umaga inception okay look
like I said guys a legendary director
I'm just giving there's none point being
coin Fincher on the other hand does it
10 out of 10 routine and then closes
with a flourish even his lesser
appreciated movies have endings that add
up to more than the sum of their parts
and for that I'm giving David Fincher
the win over Christopher Nolan that's
right the guy who made a lien three has
defeated the guy that saved comic book
movies forever no no what about justice
done hey see Tennant in theaters it's
not time travel it's clock manipulation
if I could pull a share and turn back
time maybe I'd give knowing the wind
today but I can't I have stuff to do
promises to keep and miles to go before
I sleep hey we can't all age like
Benjamin Button here's a reminder to
comment in the section below and cast
your vote
Nolan think sure it's you you're the
real winner today I'm Mark Ellis and I'm
just a figment of your mad
janeshia see you on your dreams
[Music]